passer à l'autre sujet de ce club et les
relations se tendent un peu plus entre
le royaume uni et la france sur la
question de la pêche au coeur de la
discorde l'accès aux eaux territoriales
britanniques pour les pêcheurs français
après le break site et on est passé au
stade supérieur celui des sanctions
d'abord on voit les enjeux le récit les
explications de ces tensions avec
gaspard flamand
c'est une guerre celle de la pêche post
break site qui dure depuis des mois au
coeur des débats des licences accordées
aux pêcheurs français qui leur permette
de continuer de pêcher dans certaines
eaux britanniques notamment autour des
îles de jersey et guernesey ces licences
ont été accordées suite à un accord post
break site fin 2020 avec pour seule
condition que chaque pêcheur puisse
prouver qu'ils travaillaient déjà dansé
auparavant mais français et britanniques
ne se mettent pas d'accord sur la nature
et l'ampleur des justificatifs à fournir
bilan le royaume uni a accordé un peu
plus de deux cent dix licences paris on
réclame 244 les pêcheurs sont donc loin
d'être rassurés comme ici en normandie
ça va être plus difficile oui c'est sûr
on va se retrouver tous
manger pour tout le monde au début du
mois d'octobre le premier ministre avait
demandé à l'ensemble de son gouvernement
de travailler sur d'éventuelles
sanctions n'ait rien avait été acté même
si le ton monte de plus en plus nous
étions devenus avec la ministre de la
mer à la conclusion clair aujourd'hui
que les britanniques ne veulent pas
donner à sa tante de licence non pas
parce qu'il manque d'information mais
parce qu'ils ont fait ce choix politique
un choix qui a finalement poussé la
france à prendre des mesures de
rétorsion avec des interdictions de
débarquement et des contrôles douaniers
renforcés
voilà les mesures de rétorsion cliente
était annoncée hier elles rentreront en
vigueur mardi on est clairement dans un
rapport de force stéphane entre la
france et le royaume uni avec cette
nouvelle étape qui a été franchie hier
et ses mesures de rétorsion on est quoi
dans une guerre commerciale dans une
guerre diplomatique
oui clairement mais j'ai envie de vous
dire il était temps parce que ça fait un
moment que les anglais nous balade sur
ces sujets alors me disent que les
l'accord prévoit que les poulets les
pêcheurs qui intervenait dans ces eaux
qui pêcher dans ses eaux par le passé
elle soit reconduit mais dix il ya dans
la liste des bateaux vous me présentez
il ya des gens qui ne pèserait pas sur
zone et qui voudraient avoir un accord
enfin l'autorisation de faire
aujourd'hui donc ils multiplient ils ont
multiplié tracasseries en disant on
voudrait tel et tel document etc et 10
ballons volés d'édition ce qu'on vous
accorde pas c'est parce que c'est parce
que vous n'avez pas amener les
justificatifs et les pêcheurs français
disent que c'est faux que c'est
complètement faux pour faciliter sont en
train de les promener ça dure depuis
trop longtemps
et c'est une situation compliquée il
était temps de hausser le ton après il
faudra voir si ça ça ça marche hier vous
avez cité l'interdiction débarquement
par exemple renforcement des contrôles
douaniers mais ce qu'annonce clément
bonne aussi c'est qu'ils m'ont la france
menace carrément de couper l'électricité
un deuxième temps
la pression juste le dans cette histoire
il faut avoir aussi en tête que le les
pêcheurs bretons et normands qui
interviennent dans les eaux jersiaise
pratiquer une pêche raisonnée c'est les
petits bateaux en fait c'est du petit
tonnage pas des navires usines etc ça se
passait bien pendant très longtemps
aujourd'hui il ya un problème ce qu'on
voit aussi derrière c'est la capacité de
la grande bretagne à respecter et à
honorer sa propre parole je reprend les
termes de bruno retailleau précédemment
qui dit d'y aller
les voir ces pêcheurs dans quelques
secondes mais d'abord un mot sur ces
sanctions annoncées hier par le
gouvernement c'est vrai que le
gouvernement il a beaucoup menacé de
sanctions il n'avait plus le choix il
fallait qu'il passe à l'acte c'était
fini le temps des mots oui alors au delà
effectivement du problème et du sort de
nos pêcheurs qui convient évidemment de
se régler il ya aussi un débat politique
le bric site il ya une frange certes
minoritaire mais qui existent de la
population qui a regardé ça la
population française et européenne qui a
regardé ça avec bienveillance et
inspiration on sait que le discours
souverainiste existe un il prospère on
l'a dit le débat présidentiel arrive est
donc une fois que le bauxite a
réellement été actée et qu'il entrait en
application beaucoup ont commencé à
regarder si finalement les anglais s'en
sortait bien et pour le gouvernement il
convient de ne pas
et c'est les britanniques gagner des
batailles de montrer finalement que le
bric site leur serait favorable qui
gagnant en souveraineté
effectivement à chaque fois que il est
possible de montrer que les britanniques
se prennent les pieds dans le tapis on
l'a vu lors des pénuries et bien le
gouvernement montre en disant on va
regarder le bric site c'est çà et là sur
ce dossier de la pêche le gouvernement
ne veut pas laisser passer une
éventuelle bataille symbolique est donc
derrière l'idée de couper l'électricité
aux britanniques il ya cette idée là que
le bric site ne serait pas une solution
à apporter sur le continent allez les
voir ces pêcheurs puisqu'on en parle et
on va aller voir comment ça se passe du
côté de boulogne-sur-mer où l'art colère
gronde bien évidemment et on regarde
tout le reportage burgaud lemonnier et
de marion vivre
la france a donc choisi la manière forte
pour faire plier le royaume uni il faut
dire qu'ici à boulogne-sur-mer cela fait
dix mois que les pêcheurs et les
mareyeurs attendent une réaction du
gouvernement français la crise autour
des licences de pêche menacent leurs
activités nous sommes allés les
rencontrer
george thomas et mareyeurs comme chaque
jour il participe à la criée la vente
aux enchères de poisson maquereau merlan
coquilles saint jacques ici tout
s'achète par une simple pression de
bouton des dizaines de kilos vendus en
quelques secondes et dans le plus grand
silence
sitôt ses achats terminés il rejoint ses
équipes qui charge les marchandises
autant de produits qu'ils destinent
principalement à l'export mais dont il
constate la baisse de volume la crise
des licences a fait 30 à 40% de
marchandises en moins qui est mise à
quai donc
30 à 40% de marchandises qu'on peut plus
grand de commercialiser ces
problématiques parce que nos clients au
lieu de se tourner vers boulogne comme
repère il se tourne vers d'autres pays
comme la hollande premier port de pêche
français boulogne sur mer est
aujourd'hui extrêmement dépendant des
pêches mené dans les eaux britanniques
le problème c'est que du côté français
il ya énormément petit poisson et ses
petits poissons quand ils grandissent
ils parlent au large et dans des eaux
plus profondes et les eaux profondes
sont du côté britannique l'accord signé
fin décembre entre bruxelles et londres
prévoit que pour obtenir les licences
qui permettent de travailler dans les
eaux britanniques les pêcheurs européens
et français doivent prouver qu'il le
faisait déjà par le passé mais la
plupart des petits bateaux n'ont aucun
moyen de fournir ces données aujourd'hui
près de la moitié des navires de
boulogne sur mer sont donc sans licence
il manque une quarantaine de licence et
c'est sur ces 40 on peut peut-être sauvé
la moitié mais les autres les les 20
autres bateaux nous aurons très
certainement pas leur licence et à un
moment donné sur télé jean et envisage
déjà un plan de sortie de flotte ce qui
est très dommageable pour bien sûr il ya
des bateaux qui sont en train de
chercher de vendre moi j'ai toujours
préféré la voie diplomatique
en espérant un moment donné s'il faut
sortir les arbres on sortira les armes
bien entendu mais sa nature fait des
propositions la ministre on sait qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire et justement la
ministre de la mère annick girardin a
donc annoncé aux élus des mesures de
rétorsion le député jean-pierre pont
participer à la réunion de ce mercredi à
ses yeux il était grand temps que la
france réagisse
personnellement j'aurais agi un peu plus
tôt parce que on est quand même à
presque rien on est à dix mois donc du
bric site nos marins ont été extrêmement
patient et je pense que les
les anglais ont joué
un mauvais jeu d'empêcher nos mares
agdal et alors repêché là où ils péché
normalement de mettre des tas de
contraintes je crois que c'était
inadmissible c'est de la mauvaise
volonté pure et dure donc on va rocher
nous être de très mauvaise volonté reste
à savoir si ce coup de force de la
france incitera les anglais à assouplir
leur position les pêcheurs quant à eux
attendent désormais le soutien de
l'union européenne et on le voit dans ce
reportage stéphane du côté de
boulogne-sur-mer alors c'est un séjour
du côté des élus qu'ils disent mais nous
aussi on peut être de mauvaise volonté
c'est encore plus dur du côté des
pêcheurs disent baisse il faut prendre
les armes on prendra les armes est ce
que ces sanctions ça peut changer
quelque chose pour des pêcheurs qui
attendent depuis des mois maintenant
mais j'espère y avait quand même un
salon qui sont très en difficulté ce
qu'on veut aussi dans le reportage c'est
y en a qui disent qu'ils sont en train
de désarmer ou c'est-à-dire de
d'abandonner la pêche de revendre leur
bateau turc convertir c'est quand même
un sacré un sacré problème
économiquement après juste juste pour
l'anecdote il ya encore une fois on en
revient à cette histoire de manière
générale vous avez les anglais qui sont
très forts pour défendre un intérêt et
qui savent lire entre les lignes ou
déformée au distordre aider des choses
pour pour ce pur pour servir leurs
intérêts moi ça me rappelle ça me
rappelle une très vieille histoire que
vous connaissez sans doute pas mais vous
avez le corsaire malouin surcouf robert
surcouf qui ont arraisonné un bateau
effet capturé un officier anglais une
discussion avec lui l'officier anglais
lui dit mais
vous êtes un mercenaire vous battre vous
les français vous battez pour l'argent
nous les anglais on se bat pour
l'honneur et surcouf le réponse chacun
se bat pour ce qui lui manque le plus
voilà ce que m'inspire cette histoire
autour du bric site avec les anglais est
problématique on le disait entre la
france et le royaume uni il ya aussi une
question un peu diplomatique sur cette
question de la pêche puisque paris
reproche au royaume uni de se servir de
cette question de la pêche pour masquer
les difficultés post briques cité s'en
revient un peu est ce que vous me disiez
tout à l'heure tristan est ce que ça
c'est plausible est ce que finalement ça
arrange bien le royaume uni ce conflit
avec la france et avec l'union
européenne parce que le poste briques si
ça marche pas très bien chez eux c'est
sûr que le gouvernement britannique a
besoin de batailles symboliques de
remporter quelques victoires en tout cas
de montrer que le bric site était une
bonne chose le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson c'est celui
qui a fait campagne pour ça donc il a
besoin de montrer qu'en le bric site
appliquée porte ses fruits donc
effectivement le rapport de force
doit doit continuer
néanmoins c'est vrai que brick site ou
pas il ya les liens entre le royaume uni
et l'union européenne et la france reste
de fait important et des échanges
commerciaux qui ne se sont pas arrêtés
qui subsistent
enfin de l'acquisition de l'électricité
mais il ya beaucoup comme ça de
d'interactions qui perdure et donc c'est
autant de moyens de pression de la
envers l'autre et réciproquement pour
faire pression et ses liens il continuer
et la logique voudrait que à un terrain
d'entente soit quand même trouvé au bout
d'un moment et vous ne parliez tout à
l'heure des souverainistes alors qui
inquiète peut-être la montée des
souverainistes gouvernement maintenant
la proche de la présidentielle emmanuel
macron et va faire campagne sur l'europe
il va prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne au mois de janvier sauf que
l'union européenne et se montrent pas
très solidaire de la france sur cette
question ça c'est un problème pour le
gouvernement bat pour le gouvernement
français c'est la question de la pêche
en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est un un
dossier du bric site qui concerne
particulièrement
les relations france aurait humilié mais
au-delà de cette question là il est
évident que le bris site menace de se
comment dire de saint porté sur le
continent à travers d'autres questions
mais on parle aujourd'hui du rapport de
force qui s'engage entre l'union
européenne et la pologne par exemple sur
la question de la réforme de la justice
et la question du droit il ya plein de
petits chantiers on voit dans les
propositions des candidats
principalement à droite en france le
rapport de force qui veut être engagé
avec l'union européenne sur les
questions par exemple
migratoires donc pour ne pas que
l'europe se détricote effectivement on
voit bien la nécessité pour l macron de
mettre des lignes des lignes rouges à ne
pas dépasser en tout cas parce que une
fois que
l'europe baisse pavillon sur certains
dossiers dans ce cas c'est la porte
ouverte à plein d'autres rapports de
force sur plein d'autres sujets et on
voit qu'ils sont multiples en ce moment
et merci messieurs pour ce débat
passionnant sur la pêche à
[Musique]